so this was a leeches game and max
introduces this as follows
i am white i could feel my opponents
opening didn't develop enough pieces but
i didn't figure out how to open the
position to take advantage then i was in
time trouble and things were chaotic and
i blundered the game away but i'm most
curious how to think about closed
positions like this
alright great
let's jump in this is a long game so i
might have to go a little bit faster
[Music]
all right so e4 g6 so we have a modern
d6
knight f3 hc yeah so i can see what
you're talking about your opponent's
just pushing all of his pawns out
bishop c4 so developing well so far and
e6
all right
so for now you're just developing your
pieces and you're doing a good job of it
g5 all right
all right so your opponent really asking
for it here but this can be very hard to
play against i acknowledge that and i've
talked about this on the speed run this
can be very very hard to play against
all right
now in this position i would indicate a
very interesting plan
the moment your opponent plays g5
i'm looking at this pawn and i'm saying
this is a pretty significant hook
right because one of the main avenues of
attack in such positions is the f-file
and if you've watched some of my games
you know that i love opening up the file
particularly if your opponent is not
castled
so what would be a method of trying to
get this f file open as quickly as
possible and it looks like a very bad
move see the reason a lot of you guys i
think would hesitate to play this move
is that it looks passive in and of
itself
91
but we're not playing 91 to improve the
knight we're playing it because we have
to
if i had a more active square for the
knight i would do it but i'm trying to
play f4 as quickly as possible so 91
and if your opponent would have
developed boom goes the dynamite f4
and he has no choice but to allow the f
file to get opened
um
g takes f4 bishop takes f4 and you can
try to put your queen on h5 and already
white's got a clear pathway
toward attacking black's king if that
makes sense
i love that reference too
so i would propose that as one idea
now if queen b6 you can just drop the
bishop back to e3 and defend the d2 pawn
and if queen takes b2
i um
you know i i wouldn't care about that i
would just go
knight a4 for example queen b oh no
actually let me see i mean maybe just 92
i wouldn't mind retreating more and then
maybe rerouting this knight to g3 and h5
wait max i'm not sure if you're being
sarcastic
mr mopey dick
i'm not sure if you're being sarcastic
do you want me to explain this
uh more deeply so why why is this good
oh you see it okay okay i wasn't sure if
you were people were saying that
sarcastically
okay
so that would be a good plan now you
played rookie one there's nothing wrong
with that
now a lot of you guys are thinking about
d5 here why not open up the center
and this is a very uh this is what i
what my sixth grade math teacher would
call the muppah the most popular wrong
answer
this is a move that looks very good but
the problem is that he can keep the
position closed he can play c takes d5
he takes d5 and then e5
and it's just you know we haven't
accomplished very much to open up the
position
you can try rookie one and you can try
to sacrifice on e5 but if he develops in
a timely manner and then plays knight e7
what could end up happening is that
you've actually done some damage
uh to the king side and black is now the
one who has the easier job attacking on
the king's side so for instance if you
just develop here
black's gonna go f5 and guess what those
are some pretty intimidating pawns i
have to say
um
so you gotta take this concept of
opening up the position with a pretty
serious grain of salt you played rookie
one that's patient i like it knight d7
and now you play d5 which i think is a
much better version of playing this move
so you did a great job here
because if c takes c5e takes d5 e5
um
this is a better version because this
knight is very awkward it's blocking the
bishop
who can propose a very nice move here
using the pin you can't sacrifice on e5
that's premature
but you can still use the fact that this
pawn is immobilized
and play knight d4 excellent job
where is the knight going we'll look at
this juicy weak square on f5 you can
also sack the knight on e6
this is incredibly unpleasant for black
for example if black dress fianchetto is
the bishop the knight slams into f5 this
is a fork this is total nastiness
on a grand scale this is just a pretty
common idea that you should sort of file
into your
into your mental directory
and if black plays knight e7 trying to
close down the e file
knight e6
f takes e6
checkmate to his majesty check
checkmate
yeah 96 is just another one of those
ideas to be aware of
uh if he doesn't take the knight
you know you can get the bishop out the
black's position just totally collapses
here
so to summarize the x factor here is
whether or not you have control of the e
file your opponent goes e5
and
here i think max you make the first
instructive mistake
you played the move b4 and i think
you're trying you have your
your mind in the right place
but you forgot to make a move first
i would have taken first i would have
opened up the position
uh in as much as i could and now b4
would actually be a brilliant positional
move this is the concept that i call
carving out you want the d5 square for
your queen or for your knight
what's stopping us from queen d5 was the
pawn on c6 how do we get it out of there
just shove this pawn down to b5
and undermine this pawn on c6 which
cannot be defended by any other pawns
so i love this idea of b4 but it's very
important to only do it once you've
opened up the position so this is a
matter of getting your priorities
straight to your opponent's credit he
goes c5 here keeps the position
relatively closed
and here again max i would just take the
pawn
and and i think that you over thought it
a little bit here and then i would get
the bishop out to a3 and try to get this
night out of c5 you're still much better
here
um you're still much better here
what about d5 for black well if black
plays d5
you have to you can't miss the forest
for the trees here right black is
um you know it's like trying to kill a
dinosaur by uh shooting a bb it's like
shooting a bb gun at a dinosaur
if if that makes that's a weird analogy
in one second
i have like i still have tea all over my
desk so
let me just
wipe this down a little bit
all right
so yeah this is like shooting a bb gun
at a dinosaur
do you care about this knight on c3
being hanging nah just play knight takes
e5 this is totally crushing
what to do if g4 in which position text
chess
yeah in this position right yeah
well um
daniel's style move would be b5 i would
total i would consider sacrificing the
knight here because it's so important to
get this d5 square under control all
right guys we can move on from the
kleenex
knight f6 and then something like knight
t5 we've got total domination over the
center
um
but
guess what you can also just go knight
d2 here what would be wrong with going
knight d2 and then repositioning the
knight to b3 maybe
i think that when people are learning
chess
there is a natural aversion that a lot
of people have to to making these sorts
of retreating awkward moves and what i
always say in these situations is
remember that peace placement is
temporary you can almost always
reposition a piece that's awkwardly
placed yes it's going to take you one
more move but you shouldn't that
shouldn't be a deal breaker
and that shouldn't be a cause of panic
particularly because
you have a big lead in development so
you can afford to take another move and
maybe even the knight jumps to a5 and
attacks the c6 pawn that way
yeah but you know it only takes two
moves because
uh now the g4 pawn is also hanging so
your opponent is probably going to waste
the tempo on its defense
okay
so rome wasn't built in a day so b4 c5
and you played rook b1 here
a6
uh yeah if i were your opponent i would
probably
maybe go b6 but now max you do take and
go bishop a3 excellent job b5
okay
so this is where things get juicy
uh you drop the bishop to f1 that is
fine
i would consider also taking on c5
immediately
i would consider taking on c5
immediately because if he takes on c4
then uh the b file has been opened
where can this bishop go now
where can this bishop go now
bishop b6 exactly
and after the queen moves who can
propose a good follow-up white's got a
ton of good moves here who could propose
a good move for white in this position
see i don't think we need a4 because a4
is slow you want to push the pawn to a5
but this bishop is perfectly well
defended your opponent doesn't have the
firepower to attack this bishop
instead you should notice how weak this
pawn on c4 is and find a way to attack
it so knight d2 is a great move just
getting the knight to c4 and then you
could do a little switcheroo move the
bishop back and get the knight into b6
or you could play queen e2 very simple
move you could even play rook b4 here uh
and try to get the rook to c4 and then
to c7 so
a lot of the time
you just want to think more concretely
right you want to identify weaknesses
and attack them that's one of the basic
ways of thinking about any position
and knight d2 would be the move that i
would play here
okay so you played bishop f1 first no
problem your opponent goes bishop d7
uh but rook b4 doesn't need to occur to
you i think rook b4
um
is is the fancy move knight d2 is the
move that i would play
no the queen queen 92 is not doing
anything apart from attacking c4 but it
doesn't need to be doing anything except
that it it's winning the pawn that's
enough
now if black had taken on c5
what would be the nereditskiy style move
here
i wouldn't just meekly retreat the
bishop to f1 here you have to sense that
because you have such a big lead in
development the time has come to start
sacrificing the time has come to start
just cracking through knight b5 this
isn't even really a sacrifice
i mean you get three pawns for the piece
and this is sorry and this is the sort
of position that i would evaluate
intuitively look at look at all of this
knight c6 is coming in you're pushing
that e pawn all the way to e6 black has
nothing developed
uh there's no calculation required here
it's just something you you eventually
start to sense uh when you acquire
experience in attacking chess
so
i would say this was the more incisive
approach you played bishop f1 first
but your opponent goes bishop d7 which
allows you to uh win the central pawn
this still looks great bishop g7 but now
you see now
your opponent starts to develop his
pieces
and uh you might have missed the train
here a little bit
okay
so let me see
you decided on a very interesting
approach you played f4
g takes f4 and queen h5 very creative
max very creative so you're defending
the knight and attacking f7 at the same
time fascinating
i love that idea i think that's a
brilliant idea actually
um
but it didn't quite work out we'll take
a look at that was there something more
simple available well you could have
also considered simply taking on d7
and
well if queen takes d7
how should white react in this situation
yeah definitely e5 followed by e6
totally crushing
and if bishop takes c3
this is again a case where you shouldn't
miss the forest for the trees because it
may appear that you're losing material
and technically you are
but what would be the best way to
respond here with black with with um
with white no but
you can't play knight takes b5 oh but
but you mind on the other position
oh yeah knight b5 is even better i agree
sorry i missed this move yeah knight b5
is is totally possible as well
either move would be good
yeah just just knight takes c5 knight
takes c5 bishop takes c1 queen takes c1
we've gotten rid of the fiance bishop
this queen could reroute to c3
again just visually white's position
should strike you guys as totally
overwhelming and
white has
uh technically speaking extra material
white's got what uh seven pawns to
black's five so it's in exchange for a
piece and two pawns that's
uh you know we're up material and we're
crushing here so
this is uh totally overwhelming
so that would be possible you went with
f4 and queen h5 which i find to be super
interesting okay so your opponent played
queen e7
yeah of course bishop takes e5 would not
would not have been possible because
this is a fork
um queen e7
okay so now you take on d7 bishop takes
c3
and this leads to some very ah but now
see now the problem is you can't take on
c5 anymore because the queen defends
that pawn so the knight doesn't have a
very good way out of the cage
all right
so i don't think you're in big trouble
here
but i think that um well i'm finishing
in a moment parrots
so if knight b6 then rook b8
if knight b6 then rook b8
and you do have a very ingenious method
of evacuating this night does anybody
see what i'm talking about here
remember that
you know
don't look only for night moves look for
intermediate moves that open up squares
for the night look for intermediate
moves that open up squares for the night
94 doesn't work
knight a4 doesn't work because he takes
the rook
and white's rook is overloaded we have
to take the bishop and then we
remove the pin
d6 bingo attack the queen
and reposition the knight to the center
bishop takes you when rook takes c1 and
white's got very obvious compensation
for the exchange what black's king has
no safe haven
so i would prefer white here probably
the computer could pull off some
defenses
but i would say that white's position
from a practical point of view is still
very much playable
so that would be one idea
another idea would be to play e5 and
just say basically i don't care about
any any of them any of this material i'm
going straight for black's throat
and basically just going e5
this is probably on sound
and maybe something like e6
on the other hand i'm not sure if we
have enough firepower
after something just like bishop back to
c3
yeah i don't see
i don't see a clear pathway here e takes
f7 queen takes f7
and the problem is this pesky bishop
controls z1 and it also controls e5 so
sadly
i'm not sure that we have enough here so
max you went with d6 immediately but
unfortunately he takes the knight and
now black is winning
but the game goes on
the game goes on
because your opponent blunders with
bishop d4 jack and now excellent
vigilance rook takes d4 and queen e5
winning back to peace now you're still
gonna be worse in the end
but uh this prolongs the game for sure
if i were black here i would go knight
f6
knight f6 and unfortunately your attack
fizzles out whoops sorry i keep doing
that queen f3 bishop e5
and then black and safely castle so
never give up
good tactical vigilance queen e5 check
queen takes h8 unfortunately you're
still down a bunch of pawns here
and it still looks pretty rough so now
you try to evacuate your queen that's
good thank you falc for the sub
your opponent kind of stumbles here and
you win a bunch of pawns again
e5
queen takes f4 queen takes h6 and now
you're basically in great shape again
good job queen g5
rookie one this all looks very good
i'm going a little bit faster because
i'm running out of time queen f4
bishop b2 this all looks great max
okay so here you had a pretty big chance
here you had a pretty big chance i'm i'm
sure that you're
aware of this oh you played this on the
next move you could have played e6
immediately here
um winning another pawn
but you went bishop h5 first and then e6
that that's also fine
okay so here you had a win on the spot
max can you spot it and the rule in such
positions when you can sense that your
opponent's king is on its last legs you
don't want to make any moves
automatically if you can afford to i
imagine that you might have been in time
pressure here
but if you
see the bigger picture here queen v8
track knight c8
e7 check
and you know you can even make a knight
or make a queen and this is winning so
uh for those of you watching you know
this is a good example of not making any
moves automatically and always sort of
checking for other candidate moves
uh even if you do that for five seconds
i think you have a better chance of
spotting queen v8 check because if you
pre-movie takes f7 well then you're not
going to be able to now this is still
still winning but uh this is a little
bit more complicated so here
queen d6 track correct
king c8
queen takes a6 so you pick up another
pawn
queen d6 back
yeah now things start getting a little
bit
iffy
hmm amazingly it's not so clear how to
uh
how to win i mean queen takes e7 would
be i would say the simplest
probably this is the simplest because
you're forcing black to take with the
queen if black takes with a rook
then you win with queen eight check and
rookie seven check
and you take the queen
so
when you're in time pressure if you find
a way to trade queens that could be the
most practically
astute approach and then you just start
pushing your passers
the problem with rookie 7 is you allow
this nasty check your opponent starts
checking
and now yeah and now you blunder this
rook f7 and this leads to quick
checkmate
sag that's uh that's a rough one
i think if you run toward the center
you're probably still winning here max
if you run toward the center his rook is
totally immobile so all you have to do
is escape the checks by the queen and
you could probably do that
maybe even running to g7 and one way
that i play when i'm in time pressure
and my king is in the center is
i take a second
to chart a target square for the king so
what i'm doing here is i'm saying where
do i want my king to run to
and if you ask yourself that question g7
occurs to you because
wouldn't you want to chase the rook away
from f8 and you just
run you run to that square
in any way that you can
king g4 also escapes the checks by the
way so you should probably go here
but you basically run toward your target
square or your target area and that
could really help you avoid the checks
king g6
block with a queen
queen takes c2 king g7 so
that's a pretty good technique even when
you're not in time pressure for finding
ways to evade the checks so
this was a rough one i think you played
an excellent game honestly
um to recap
in this position the idea of opening the
f file by pushing the f1 so move the
knight away and then play f4 that's a
very
uh
very um
typical and very important pattern to be
aware of when your opponent plays g5
um d5 was excellent here
you know try to keep your priorities in
order your priority number one is to
open up the position so taking the pawn
first would have been good
and uh you know here there were a couple
of moments where you could have played a
little bit more incisively
i feel like maybe you reacted a little
bit too automatically to some of these
although you thought for a minute 54 so
i feel like maybe you were considering a
sack but always consider all of the
captures
bishop takes e5 and then when you have
this kind of massive lead in development
that's when you should start considering
sacrifices that open up the position
completely because that allows you to
just uh strike at your opponent before
they get a chance to develop yeah of
course no i'm having a lot of fun
uh it's it's my pleasure so bishop d7
and you know sometimes
uh you came up with a very creative idea
and i almost feel bad
uh criticizing you for this because of
how creative this concept is
but
sometimes just going for the simple
approach
and giving up a little bit of material
sometimes that's the best thing you can
do
you know
uh sometimes
these kinds of creative approaches uh
just give your opponent a little bit too
much time to stabilize thank you aggro
collar for the prime yeah this is about
calculating
further exactly
so
this is about calculating as far down as
you can if you had calculated to this
point i think you would have noticed
that too many of your pieces hang are
hanging you had an option of going
knight b6 and d6
you know this concept of opening up a
square for one of your pieces by pushing
out a pawn is important you see this in
a lot of different types of positions
great job not losing hope
and seeing rook takes d4 this is awesome
and you know phenomenal job recovering
from
you know that setback you did just you
know this stretch was flawless
you spotted e6
and you know maybe the most important
lesson out of the time scramble would
have been to
uh to take just a second or two
and consider all the other candidate
moves it's easy for me to say that
uh but when you do that you alert
yourself sometimes to the possibility of
these knockout blows particularly when
the king is is as weak as it is and then
finally
uh going you know forcing the queen
trade as tempting as it might be to go
for checkmate just you know taking a
second and forcing the queen trade
could could allow you to win a game and
even in an acute time scramble so queen
takes c7 here might have been the more
practically
uh you know might have been the more
pragmatic choice and then finally uh
getting the king to a predetermined
square
could be um something to consider when
you've got only a couple of seconds left
and your king is getting hunted down
again easy for me to say but
something to
help you
help you
manage in such positions
okay
all right so
definitely an excellent game thanks
again for not being afraid to send in a
loss i know this was a painful one
but uh this was a tremendously
instructive game so many interesting so
many interesting things happened
ultimately remember that when your
opponent pushes a lot of pawns in the
opening
it is the right approach to open up the
position but you don't want to do that
blindly you want to do that in a very
careful manner because if you do it
prematurely or you do it in the wrong
way you you let your opponent close down
the center permanently and that could
cost you the game so i love that you
played rookie one here
in order to prepare d5 that was very
good uh opening play so
nice game man
yvonne thank you for the 500 and ld2775
for the four months
i have to run guys thank you everybody
for the support
um
this was these were two awesome games
amanda and and max thank you for
submitting
uh such instructive games this has been
a lot of fun i think this is the start
of a very good series i'll put this out
on youtube
so thank you guys so much for all of the
support it's much appreciated i'm happy
that people found this instructive and
thanks for hanging out take care and see
you guys soon bye
[Music]